what's your issue with mouthwash about
40 percent of people in this country
regularly use antiseptic mouthwash which
basically indiscriminately nukes the
bacteria in the mouth what could be the
harm of this you might say to yourself
so it turns out that they're not just
doing bad things occasionally they're
actually also doing good things and so
by regularly using antiseptic mouthwash
what you're doing is you're killing off
bacteria that among other things are
involved in the nitric oxide pathway in
your body so when we consume fruits and
vegetables that contain compounds called
nitrates bacteria in our mouths reduce
nitrite to nitrate which is then what
enters this nitric oxide pathway and
nitric oxide is a gas that we create in
our blood vessels that increases blood
flow reduces blood pressure you're
basically negating your ability to
derive a cardio protective effect of
healthy foods and so they've done
studies that have found obese
participants that regularly use
antiseptic mouthwash were at Double the
odds of developing hypertension and they
saw a 50 increased risk of developing
type 2 diabetes